[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum thanks for joining me
again
uh it's nice to have ryan here in the
room with me i'm not alone
i'm not alone i'm not alone
so please forgive me no i'm not in love
remember i'm not
in love it was a 70s song i hope you
guys had a great week
thank you for uh for again uh supporting
the show listening to it subscribing to
it
and also if you're listening for the
first time and you're just a big lance
bass fan that's perfectly okay
but uh please subscribe and follow us at
uh
insiderviewpodcast on instagram and
facebook
and at insideviewpod on the twitter
by the way uh william shatner tweeted me
i saw he tweeted me says michael
rosenbaum blah blah blah maybe you
should
something about you know talking to this
other fan that was
tweeting but he he singled me out
and i go william shatner well if you say
so holy crap one of my heroes is bill
shatner
i go maybe you come on the podcast and
he goes oh i'm sorry i don't i don't
book
i don't book podcasts well i could have
someone else book it for you sir i don't
think
he's in his 80s he's 90 i think is he 90
how old's bill shatner
all right right now everybody guess a
number guess a number i'm going to tell
you how old he is
i'm going to say he's 87. 85.
okay what do you guys think out there
here is the answer
he just turned 89 years old [ __ ] and i
just saw him at a convention and uh we
talked he's always reading
uh you know i don't want to get into it
really but i started to watch
the vow on hbo max oh yeah
and i didn't really know anything you
know obviously you know one of my
co-stars
allison was a part of that and uh didn't
go
well to say the least but um
i uh noticed in my twitter feed it's
it's a very provocative
it's an insane story and in fact i when
i was watching the first episode
you know it became this this cult and a
lot of dark [ __ ] happens i'm not gonna
give it away you should
watch it but um the first episode i'm
like
i could use that i could use like
self-esteem
and all these certain things that i was
like i could see i could understand why
people get into it
yeah and then unfortunately
you know yeah [ __ ] goes on and
uh bad people uh
i just have so many questions and and my
point of this whole thing
is it it's tragic it's tragic
but when i was on twitter i noticed
someone liked to tweet or said something
and i go huh oh i follow them they
follow me oh i know this person i've
been
for years i just haven't and i realize
it's one of the
main people one of the main people's
people on the documentary and
uh this person i said hey
you know tell me to f off but i'd love
to have it on the show and talk about
you know
talk about adversity talk about
i mean people were branded women were
branded
they were slaves and like all this cr
you know crazy [ __ ] have you seen it
no oh and i really didn't know much
about it
but i'll get into it later because we
have a guest coming on the show in a few
weeks
i i feel like they're very brave i mean
i don't think you get it most people
in fact i would say 99 of people get
into something
an organization because at that moment
in time
that's what they need and you don't
think cult
you don't think that you think no these
are just nice people who
understand me who i'm learning from i'm
not caught up in the [ __ ] world
you feel like you're somebody you're
something it gives you
again we'll talk to this person so i
understand
and then it falls apart and you're like
how did this happen
and uh hopefully luckily you know some
people left
early because they're like something's
weird something's not right i'm getting
the hell out
i won't name those people but good for
them for having that insight or that um
what's the word
uh self-awareness maybe maybe
self-awareness i'm
you're here for words but anyway that
guest uh is coming on in a few weeks and
you know talk about if you're going
through anxiety and all that stuff boy
this is a story that uh you should
listen to
and i'm very excited about this person
coming on so there's that i want to
thank all my patrons
uh again without you guys where would i
be
all the listeners i noticed the
subscriptions are getting higher on
youtube that's so cool man
thank you all for doing that thank you
for uh watching our stage it we just
recorded
uh two days in the studio for our album
just very exciting stuff and i i
appreciate the support uh patreon if
you're not on patreon check it out
patreon.com
it's on an app but looking inside of you
on patreon patreon
and uh it's people who support the show
on another level and uh there's a lot of
goodies like inside of me
where i uh interview myself i usually
dress up as characters and
i always do actually i i don't have to
but i do it
i'm alone and i like to dress up i've
been a female i've been this australian
punk i've been this
country boy clueless whatever i've been
a woman
anyway and we do a lot of other fun
stuff and
uh the inside of you merch store online
inside of you online store we got new
wine glasses i have to give you a wine
glass oh really it's a wine stem less
wine glass and looks inside
here and getting free [ __ ] you do i gave
you towels we got towels i get
what else have i given here the mask you
give me the flip-flops
mugs oh don't don't mention the
flip-flops because i don't have those
online those are just a rare thing maybe
i'll put them online i don't know
i just like stuff i like merch so uh uh
there there you go all right my guest
today
you know him from one of the biggest
bands of all time in sync
he's a wonderful guy i love him he's
super talented he's got
some great projects coming up he's got
his own podcast
i love hearing the stories about nsync
you're gonna like them
and he talks about coming out he's very
brave
and um we really we get a little deep
so i think you're gonna like this let's
let's check it out tell me if you how
you feel about it
let's get inside of lance pass it's my
point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
99.5 wkdq we got
lance bass here in the studio i'm
kidding if i talk like that would you
please kiss me
what's up how are you dude what's up i
mean same stuff
just haven't left this green couch in
about five months
uh i'm color blind but i assume it is
green isn't it it is
a nice lime green although i do see
color i mean i can see colors i just
can't differentiate some
um you are full of color you've got
roses on your shirt is that because
you're talking to rosenbaum today or
what
duh oh my god i didn't think you would
like put that together but yes this is
my rose and bomb shirt you're a liar
you you didn't think about it you didn't
think about me till you said five
minutes go leave so what's next
michael rosenbaum who am i i'm not
jewish is that my right
it's not true i look forward to talking
to you every single time
well it's been a long time yes i know we
haven't like i haven't seen you in
person in
a while i've seen anyone in a while but
yeah
have you been sitting on that green
couch for the last five months
yeah this is where i do my podcast right
here so it's just every day
wow listen this is truth i want to talk
truth today
we we always talk truth on the show but
do you i mean look you're you're a fun
guy you're a nice guy you're you're
charitable philanthropic you're you know
talent all that crap right
all that crap but like sometimes i i can
like
feel like i'm losing my mind like some
days i
you know the other day there was no
remember there was no there was no uh
internet and i've been having problems
with the internet and i just it was one
of those days and i had to cancel i hate
cancelling on people i was like this
isn't my fault i always feel like i'm
always on time
have you felt any anxiousness where
someone's been like whether it's your
husband
or what you know do you say husband is
that incorrect
yeah that's correct right i i thought
you were going to correct me i was like
yeah husband
yeah that's right we've evolved a little
at least yeah
husband is the word thank god yes but
does he ever say
does he look at you and say lance
[ __ ] off you're going crazy right now um
not really he's just the most easy going
person in the world so it's really hard
to piss him off and it's and i've tried
for 10 years um it's just he's just not
that type of person which is
at first was hard to kind of get used to
because my relationships i always dated
a lot of brazilians so it was very like
passionate relationships right
and i always feel that oh well in a real
relationship you're supposed to fight
hard right
make up hard um then when i met him i
realized oh wait
you don't have to fight to show that you
love each other
interesting yeah now i want to hear
about these fights with the brazilian
guys like lance
why are you so i don't know boring why
can't we go on a terrible accident but
what
what were those like do you remember any
of the past any fights that you were
like oh my god oh yeah
it always stems from the same thing um
they would always just get jealous
if i was like you know speaking to
someone you know
they all they always think that you're
cheating on them that was it
you're cheating okay like uh no so it
was
and the funny thing is they were the
ones that were cheating
really every time oh yeah like every
time yeah
and you never cheated you're not that
guy no i don't do that
well i mean i don't think i can you know
being who i am like
people are going to talk [ __ ] about me
you know right i mean jeez i can't
i can't even imagine like you know so
they were it was all out of insecurity
it was all out of like whatever it was
that's all you knew and now you come in
a new relationship have you been married
for what six years
uh it'll be six in december yeah all
right and it's just like
the extreme opposite of what you're used
to
now that's that's important to because
it's hard especially me like you know
i've been dating and this and that
and you always think this is my type
this is what i want
this is what i should have i've always
thought i should be with this type of
girl
yeah now now how hard is that that's
hard to then just say
this isn't working when does that
moment come about where you're like this
hasn't been working i've got to try
something new
was that what it was oh yeah i mean for
sure it wasn't even
it wasn't a conscious thing i don't
think i just think when it landed in my
lap
i started realizing a few months and
like oh this is
different in a really good way um
so you know i just i wasn't i wasn't
used to it and i've just never been in a
relationship where
everything was just always hunky-dory
what did you clean like not real
did you question it like almost like
this is not who i should be with i can't
be with this guy he's too mellow he's
too nice
oh and at first i thought he was like
faking it so i'm like okay there's no
way this guy can be like
this nice and this easy going like this
is ridiculous like
why is he lying to me but then you know
one
two three four ten years later you're
like
the same person so yeah just it's who he
is
did you ever do things where you're like
i want to get under a skin i want to get
a rise out of him i want to see him flip
his lid oh yeah all the time especially
early on in our relationship i wanted to
kind of test those boundaries
um and annoy him a little bit just to
see how he would react
and i wouldn't get a reaction out of him
so it made me stop when was the moment
where you said
all right you're for real
it was very quickly yeah i mean uh god
we moved in together
probably like five months after we
started dating
so it was around like the five month
mark where i'm like yeah
this is this is my man wow
i love that it gives me hope you know it
does give me hope
uh yeah i mean it's just it's
unbelievable how
i think you have to sometimes
i mean i go to therapy i do all these
things i just i you know you think you
have a type and then one day you're like
well that's just not working for me do i
want to be alone for the rest of my life
and i think we all tell ourselves
especially when we're young like
what my type is you know it's like
describing your personalities like i'm
the shy one but then you start
and you start feeling like you have to
be that way
you know and then in relationships like
well no i'm attracted to the brazilian
so i can only date brazilians like you
just get in this like kind of rut of
like
what people are expecting you to be um
and then you just kind of grow out of it
at some point was he a fan of yours
no definitely not no he was
i mean if he were to choose backstreet
or insane could probably be backstreet
um
because his sister was into it his twin
sister so uh
yeah they did not grow up in sing fans
did he know the words to any of your
songs it was
nothing nothing no not at all no and you
like that
i mean yeah i mean it's uh i mean it's
refreshing for sure
um i mean it doesn't bother me if
someone liked my stuff you know before
we met
uh but yeah he was he was very removed
from the whole nsync experience and you
believed it
you believed that he didn't because i've
had some you know i've
look i i could give you bad examples
where you know many years ago i haven't
been a club in 15 years but
my dog's barking but that's just life
because i'm quarantined and they're here
and that's what it is
but i've been in you know i remember
going to a club and some girl comes up
to me and she's just drunk
and she's like i don't know who you are
i don't care
i don't like are you someone i should
know
i you know and i was just like uh why
are you talking to me then if i
i mean why go up to someone randomly and
it was just
it used to happen to me all the time and
i love the onesie and they're always
like a little drunk or a lot of drunk
and they're like
hey i don't recognize you
i'm like okay they're like no i don't i
don't know who
are you like why would you come up to
someone and say i don't recognize you
right right have you had yeah have you
had people come up to you
i've had this i mean i've had where
they're just like oh my gosh you you
look so much better on the show
or movie not only that
i get i get this like when i meet people
in person like wow
you're like you're better looking in per
person like really better looking
person they're like oh okay i guess i
look like
hideous on television i i think they're
in their minds they're thinking they're
i'm gonna go up to lance bass and i'm
gonna say this
and he's gonna be like oh not only was
it uh
a nice thing to say because that's in
their mind but uh it was
really honest which most people pre i
think a lot of people when they approach
celebrities or whatever
they think that they want to hear things
that no one else will say
right no one's said this before right
lance
let me tell you something and like
you're going to look at them and think
oh my god
this is i need to be with this i need to
hang out with this person this is yeah
we need to be friends now because yeah
you're so different yeah
oh i mean i i look at all this stuff and
you're just
you're so busy i mean you got the deli
pop cast with lance bash
the movie with tristar i i'm only saying
this part because
i i hope this is real because it just
sounds really good
the movie that you have in development
about two girls who won an rv
on the price is right and followed
insync around on tour
that's a true story it is a true story
yeah if you were an instinct fan
especially during our pop odyssey uh
tour days um yeah these two girls that
weren't even in sync fans they were
you know they were 21 years old so they
were a little too old to be
to be insane fans they
hatched a plan thought it'd be funny to
hey let's go to the price is right one
of us will win a winnebago and enough
money to be able to follow in sync
on their stadium tour for three months
and
the joke became reality they one of them
got on the show
she won a winnebago like i don't know
how she
i and how do you how do you know that
you're gonna be have a chance to win
winnebago
and it was the uh the biggest prize ever
given on the price is right
to date um and yeah and she won it and
they followed us
the whole entire summer and it was just
this amazing girls
road trip this kind of coming of age
road trip that
you know was hilarious because so much
[ __ ] happened but how many times on this
tour
do you meet these girls or did you see
them um
we didn't know about it until the last
week of the tour
yeah the fans knew because you know back
in the day there was no social media so
the fans
you know the only way they need to have
gas money to get to the next city
um was fans in aol chat rooms
they would meet the fans in chat rooms
and then they would they would help them
get to the next city
so it was but we didn't know this until
the last week
of tour and i was watching trl and
carson daly's on the winnebago out in
the parking lot in san diego
and i'm watching this store and like
well this is the coolest thing ever so
me and the boys go out to winnebago and
say hello and we
give them tickets to the rest of the
shows which we would have given them
tickets to all the shows if we would
have known this but so we
we gave them tickets for the rest of the
shows and uh it was just amazing and i
remember
at that moment this was wow 20 years ago
i remember thinking this is the best
movie
ever like this would be that's what i
thought it's so incredible
yeah and then i've so i've been pitching
it for 20 years
and no one would buy this thing um so
then
i you know i just did a movie last year
uh about luproma this documentary about
luke roman
and i think it was variety or whoever
was asking what's your next project you
want to do i said well i've always
wanted to sell this
rv movie and i told them you know kind
of the premise of it
and the chairman of sony called me the
next day it's like we're doing this
movie
i'm like okay it's the fastest cell i've
ever had
he goes but you don't understand why he
goes one of the girls
they're called winter meredith was his
nanny for the last few years so he knew
the story already what he knew this girl
yeah what are the odds of that i mean it
was fate it had to have happened so
you know immediately sony trust i was
like yup this is it we're doing that now
do you have to get the rights from the
girls because i mean
it's it's a story it's their story but
you can't copyright an experience you
could you can go to some party and go i
remember when this guy drank
10 beers and then [ __ ] a beer can
i'm gonna write a movie i don't know why
that was the story i just
but you could write about that and i go
hey i [ __ ] that beer can you can't steal
my store happen to me
can you do that did you go through the
whole legal [ __ ] i mean you can
um you know they're involved with us
we've actually you know become close
which is nice they're lovely lovely
girls they haven't spoken to each other
in years but you know life
you know set you apart but now they're
really close
again they started their own instagram
account about you know
the rv girls um but yeah
you can you know how it is with you can
option
a newspaper article so i mean these
girls are public domain because
they were famous and uh you know
newspapers and magazines wrote about
them so you can actually legally
get you know uh go to the newspaper and
say okay we want to
option this article you know to write
this story uh but we didn't have to do
that because we have the girls on board
with us so
also based that you say based on true
events and that's yes
and by the way where's the rv don't you
want to know what happened to the rv
uh the rv got sold i don't know where it
is but rv is sold i would love to find
out where that actually is because it
would be fun to use the real
rv in the movie um and this step
and now that it's 20 years later we had
to change the
about what everything is right
originally it was just going to be the
original story of
these you know 21 year olds that did
this but uh
now we're going to place it in 2021
where now the girls are 40 and now
having this kind of like midlife crisis
type situation and they want to
recapture their youth by doing this road
trip again
because you know their favorite band
which probably won't be in sync in the
movie
um has you know their walk of you know
fame star
ceremony so this is their excuse to do
it all over again
but it could be cool if you got the boys
together
and they said you at this point in their
lives in sync
which i know everybody's asked you a
million times wants to do the reunion
tour
and they're like oh my god it's our
childhood dreams
we should you know and then they they go
see the old that's i think there's more
comedy i didn't write the thing this is
your project
no i'm just great and i would love
because my
my idea from the very beginning was you
know i i thought it was a little too
cheesy to use real
nsync and plus i mean you know boy band
fans they're
they're very loyal so i don't even know
if half the backstreet fans would come
see this movie just because it was about
in sync you know so
i think it's funnier to be in a
fictitious world and that way at the end
of the movie you can really stunt cast
that band when you finally see it
with you know ryan reynolds jake
gyllenhaal and like all those kind of
people
i think that would just be a funnier bit
at the end i'm in i
read that i go this is a great idea
there's no funny movies out there i
how many times do they like oh
exclusively on this and it's like you're
watching
when is another funny move what's the
last funny movie that you remember
seeing
honestly i mean i i like to re-watch
movies
and the last one that actually made me
laugh out loud was three amigos
like 50 times but like i just love it
and then like
behind you the jerk like i just watched
that the other day
uh oh yeah it's just it's interesting i
mean i could watch zombie boy and i
could watch
uh you know the old sandler movies like
you know the happy gilmores and the
things and the
anything with kristen wiig i actually i
loved uh
sandler's new movie uh with jennifer
anderson i thought that was really like
i didn't see that what is that funny
yeah it's on netflix i think or hulu
really
i should check that out oh yeah i mean i
loved it i thought it was i thought it
was silly and fun
but look at this you have a new line of
drink mixers you have a
a partner with prosecco trailer called
bubble tap trailer you have a food home
line with qvc
let me ask you this this makes me think
one of two things
one you just love being busy you're an
entrepreneur
you love to just create you love to have
income coming in
have the fun of doing all these things
or you lost
all your money in nsync you have nothing
left and you're starting an empire all
over again
uh no it's definitely the first one um
you know it's
you know a lot of my projects don't make
money so it's not it's definitely not
about the income coming in
um all my businesses that we're
launching this year
it really hurt um you know 2020 was
going to be a huge year for
lbp last fast productions um we were
launching virgin fest
with sir richard branson in june which
is going to be
an incredible music festival when we are
able to do it but it's postponed
um the mixer line i was coming out with
is now completely changed
we had to re-brand the whole entire
thing and that'll be coming out
hopefully by the end of the year
um so and in the bubble tap trailer of
course because of covid
is not running right now so all of my
businesses are kind of dormant right now
um except the podcast
and the writing of this movie right now
and then there's another tv show that
i'm doing
that we're writing right now too so you
like keeping busy you don't you're not
one of those
if you have too much time on your hands
oh it's the worst what happens to you
i usually get sick yeah if i if i if i
get down time
like i start kind of shutting down it's
very strange but i've been that way
since i was you know a kid i joined in
sync when i was 16 and
i mean your schedule just like bam bam
so you get used to this
life of if you don't have something
going on every minute
you feel like you're being lazy um that
you're not working
so you know after in sync i just kind of
kept that schedule and always you know
my my brain doesn't stop creating things
so
the tv and film like it's just like
constantly just creating stuff so
it doesn't stop so i needed to put that
into you know a good outlet
i mean aren't you fatigued with all the
work that you do constantly doing things
i always look at this and i'm like
i don't like honestly i don't like i
look at some careers who who have
millions and millions of dollars in
mansions and jets and i'm like
not for a million years i don't want
that life i don't want to work
this movie into another movie into a
show and to this into that
i don't know how people do that now what
what do you you and you have to do that
yeah i mean and you know i'm trying to
get to a point where i don't have to be
that crazy you know i always said at 40
i wanted to
kind of semi-retire from in front of the
camera you know and really focus on
being behind the camera
and that's what i'm kind to parlaying
into right now is
you know i i don't want to have to
constantly be
like you know getting jobs on tv just to
keep you know relevant whatever
i just want to be behind the scenes
write and produce great things
help other people out and enjoy life
actually
you know enjoy vacations and having some
time off and
we're starting a family now so i just
want to focus on kids
um and you know and i've been working so
hard just to get to that level
um so that's why 2020 was really
depressing because
all these projects were finally gonna
launch and then all i had to do was
manage them
um and unfortunately that's delayed now
but starting
starting a family you want to have kids
oh yeah oh yeah wow how old are you now
i'm 41. no you're young you're young
yeah i mean yeah i'm young um
but i always said to myself look you
know i wanted a kid by 40. like you know
it's like if i'm gonna have kids like
40s the age you know you don't want to
be too old with a grandparent and all
that type of stuff
uh so yeah i and michael wants kids
you're both on the same page
oh yeah i mean that was one of the
reasons i knew
i was going to marry him because we we
both wanted to have kids
you know uh early on in our relationship
so then
yeah just time kind of gets away and
then we started
you know this ivf process about three
years ago
um and it's just been not a great
experience i mean i know a lot of people
have a lot of failed ivf
experiences but ours is just it's we've
gone through
so many donors and now so many
surrogates it's just been such a process
and you know last year we were pregnant
for you know a few weeks and
unfortunately lost
uh both of them uh and so now we've
made our embryos again and now we're
waiting for a surrogate uh we gotta find
another surrogate in order to get
pregnant because we were supposed to be
pregnant last week
and then our surrogate unfortunately
found a medical
issue that she can't carry the kids so
uh we got to start all over again
it's been stressful i'm sorry that sucks
but you know what you know it's gonna
happen
just know it's gonna happen and maybe
with all the [ __ ] that's going on
maybe it'll be a nice christmas surprise
or hanukkah who knows i mean i hope so
and no and worst case if it doesn't work
this time
i mean we want to adopt anyway so we'll
just immediately go into adoption
inside of you is brought to you by
neutrophil uh
30 million women are impacted by
weakened or thinning hair
it happens to women just as easily as it
happens to men um
you know i played a bald guy for seven
years i have a lot of friends who are
bald
and uh you know some people are
comfortable with it and some people
aren't
and so you should have that choice of
what you want to do and and
neutral fall is really a great product
if you're among one of these 30 million
women who are impacted by uh weakened or
thinning hair
you're not alone obviously and there's a
solution you can trust to deliver
results
thousands of women have taken back
control of their hair with neutrophil
with many users raving that the
supplement not only transformed their
hair
but restored their confidence too
neutral fall offers two targeted
formulas for women that are clinically
shown to improve hair growth and
thickness with less shedding
through all stages of life healthier
hair growth takes time
you'll begin to experience thicker
stronger faster growing hair in three to
six months
and in a clinical study eighty-six
percent of women reported improved hair
growth after six
months more than fifteen hundred top
doctors recommended neutrophil as an
effective
and high quality solution for healthy
hair you can grow
thicker healthier hair and support our
show
by going to nutrafall.com and using the
promo code inside
and new customers will get 20 off
this is their best offer available
anywhere
plus free shipping on every order get 20
off at nutrafall.com spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l-dot-com
promo code inside
you're going to be a good dad i hope so
i had great parents
um no that was no yeah go ahead no
continue
yeah i mean i just uh i just i've always
wanted to be a dad you know
i just i want to help make i don't know
like human beings that are just that
have empathy
and i want to do good for the world you
know i feel like i have to combat all
this crazy
just ignorant people being born with
like smart people it's not the ignorant
people being born it's the ignorant
parents giving birth to those kids
you're not born ignorant i think you
know it's it's like you if you
you're a product of your own environment
you know you're raised if your parents
are fighting and hitting each other and
drinking you're in trouble
if they're talking if they're saying
racial slurs and this and that what's
gonna happen to you nine times out of
ten you become the racist
very few people get out of that break
that uh so yeah that's
it i think the kids in good hands is
what i'll say yeah
i hope so but you said your parents were
good parents now i was thinking about
that because
they were conservative probably went to
church a lot religious right
so the first thing that i think of is
when lance comes out
most people it's a shame
but they hold on to it for many many
more years so they keep it from their
parents because they're like they you
don't understand you don't understand my
mom you don't understand my dad
they would just was it was it like that
or not at all with you
yeah we uh i mean most of us gay people
we stay in the closet
because of our families i mean that is
that's the number one reason that we're
too embarrassed to
you know tell our families um because we
just don't want to disappoint them and
coming from a place where i came from in
mississippi
you know it was it was a taboo like no
not
one person in my high school was gay you
know of course there were but like
no one ever admitted it um and even
today it's still
a really hard place to admit that you're
gay i mean it's getting better and the
younger generations are fine but
that older generation still holds on to
this hatefulness of the gay community
so coming out to my family was you know
it scared me
um my friends knew i was gay i was
already on boyfriend number three before
i came out to my parents
because i wanted when they knew about me
i wanted to make sure that i was in this
like
really great relationship to show them
that this is about love this isn't about
sex this is about love and i thought
that would be a way
easier way to kind of express who i was
by letting them meet but you know the
love of my life um
and i didn't know what to expect and
when i
you know when they found out
i i knew that they would be supportive
you know in a way but i didn't know they
would be that supportive
um you know my mom it took her a couple
of days to be able to like
you know catch her breath to be able to
talk about it because it just
surprised them i'm like really did it
really surprise you
i thought it was a little obvious but i
mean mom's just they don't they don't
parents have the blinders on
they're not my kids perfect my kids
beautiful my kids they
and you all have their own they have
their vision for you so
you know my mom had the person i was
going to marry what the kids were going
to be like i mean they they have this
vision of what your life is going to be
and then you know you're about to
destroy that vision for them
so you know i can see them kind of like
man and then the other thing was my mom
was so upset
um the first couple days not because i
was gay but
she was upset that the world was gonna
hate her son
like she immediately was like half the
world is gonna hate my son now and she
does
not want that you know no no parent
wants that for their kid
so that's the disappointment i think
you've seen a lot of families of
um it's not they're embarrassed or mad
that their kids gay but
they just hate how the world is going to
treat them and they don't want that
yeah wow that's heavy that's heavy you
think about
thinking the half of the world is going
to hate my son and the reality is
the fun thing is like my dad who i
thought you know he's very conservative
like very quiet and
i thought he would be the one with the
issue um but he was the first to be like
well are you being safe like yeah he
goes by me like it was just so
nonchalant like what uh it was very
and i mean my my whole family they're
they're all trump supporters like
very conservative yeah um yeah but they
were
so did you argue with them at this point
uh not anymore what's the point
what's the
you know because one i i hate politics
but as a gay
man you gotta be political and you know
and i have just become political because
i just feel like
there's a lot of things that need to be
helped in this planet environment
whatever
lgbt rights it's you know it's scary
um so yeah i i wanted just to
i don't know educate them and like or at
least understand
why they still support someone like that
and it just got hated too much like
there was just too much
i don't know it's hard for someone that
follows trump
to defend him right i mean you can't
really defend what he's doing so
in defending they get defensive and then
they start
he goes nowhere right right and then
they start saying well you live in this
little
little bubble of hollywood and you don't
know what's really happening in the
world
like or yeah you're in the little small
bubble in little town mississippi that
doesn't know
anything about the world like which one
makes more sense
you know and and you try to do in a
respectful way but there's
when people aren't hearing what they
want to hear they're not taking it as a
respectful way they think that that
you're judging them
that you're yelling at them and that you
think they're stupid
because i hear that a lot they're like
you just think i'm stupid i'm like no
i'm not calling you stupid i'm saying
yeah you might be
have some ignorant thoughts but
ignorance is not a bad
thing like we're all ignorant oh yeah
i'm an idiot
oh yeah we're ignorant to most things um
so we have to learn and be willing to
you know learn about other things but
these supporters they don't they don't
want to learn anything they have their
own mindset
well you know what i i think it's it
really comes down to like one or two
issues
it's like honestly if trump was anti-uh
anti-abortion or a pro-abortion
pro-women's rights let's call it not
pro-abortion let's say
women's rights and pro and women should
choose or whatever
you know how many millions of people
then would probably
vote i'm not saying there's like two
things there's abortion
maybe i found the two things because i
interview a lot of people what are they
very interested in all that
and here are the top two reasons why
especially
southern conservatives support trump
and the republican platform number one
abortion
that is abortion abortion abortion
you're killing children
how could i ever support a teen that
wants to kill children
you know they don't they don't get
educated on why it's not
killing children and if you have planned
parenthood
it's actually saves you know like
there's less abortions with planned
parenthood
by the way if you're ultimately how's
that go just go ahead go ahead
all right but if your ultimate goal is
to have the least amount of abortions
then we need to tackle that and make it
you know where people don't get pregnant
the first time and that's your planned
parenthood and all that
and then the number two that i keep
hearing um
is because he wants to bring prayer back
to schools
so it's prayer in schools and abortion
and then i tell them like well you do
know
it is not illegal to pray in school
and to have prayer groups and all that
like they people think
that it's illegal to bring a bible on
campus to pray on campus
they're just so it's this there's all
this misinformation out there so
one main thing that they're holding on
to why they stick with this party
it's just it's just a lie it's a
complete lie yeah
well there we go talking about politics
i know i know and on my show too like
we're political free shipping
pop culture and then all of a sudden we
get into we're like damn it we got into
politics again
yeah uh let me ask you this do you think
your mother and father
absolutely for a time did you and did
you think this
do you think they looked at you
differently even though they said they
accept you and all these things did you
still
feel like they're still judging me i
could feel it or family members or
things
even though they said no we love you
lance we're in no they all think and
it's not the gay thing it's
it's the the hollywood thing you know
they
they think i am so crazy and everything
that i believe in is just so off the
wall and like
crazy that they they feel bad for me
like my whole entire
mississippi family like uh i mean he's
he's going crazy like he believes all
this [ __ ]
but uh yeah i mean it's it's really it's
hard
my gosh but the boys the uh the guys in
the band they were all cool with it
right
oh god yeah and the guys i mean they
knew they all kind of they assumed
uh you know um so they were not
surprised
you know when i came out um and super
supportive i mean they've
one of the i remember being in the group
and obviously i knew i was gay my whole
life so
you know it was scary to you know have
to talk to your new best friends about
relationships and all that type of stuff
so i knew that at some point they were
gonna find out because
i wasn't really dating girls and i
wasn't having sex
you know with fans and all that type of
stuff so uh
yeah it was but i also knew that they
would be very accepting because
of just how they interacted with the gay
people that we would interact with you
know we're in the entertainment business
so our choreographers our makeup people
like all that
and so i knew the love they had for lgbt
so i knew that it would never be
an issue do you think guys like straight
guys
or girls do you think there's this sort
of
when they're around a gay guy or maybe
even a black guy
i'm getting i'm getting to the point
here do you feel like they sort of put
something
on where it's like for instance i've
been around some of my black friends and
someone will come along and all of a
sudden i'm like
the white guy is going oh yeah man you
know totally man yeah see we
see what you're saying man i'm like what
the [ __ ] are you talking like that for
because you're around a black guy did
people do that with maybe a gay man like
oh i know right and all of a sudden
they're acting like they think that's
the stereotype
do you ever get that you're like what
the [ __ ] is this yeah i mean definitely
i mean i definitely feel it more with
the black community when i'm around
black friends and everyone starts you
know just getting into the culture
you know right it's kind of like madonna
living in england now she has a british
accent
just you know just happens i don't know
but with this
yeah i haven't seen that too much around
me but
i do get a little more like yas queens
from like straight people
which i don't know if that's you know
been in many people's vocabulary the
last few years
but i get a lot of yaz queens right i
mean i think maybe it's also like
trying to fit in in their minds trying
to say i appreciate you
uh i'm here i like you i i don't know
what it is i don't think it's like
saying
[ __ ] you look what i'm it's just i
noticed those things right you always
i could tell and my black friends would
notice he's like cheering out he was
talking to me
i'm like yeah man you should say
something he's like now you're talking
to me like that
don't say that rosa don't talk but um
you know when you you had all the guys
on it was a 20-year reunion uh thing
right you just had that march was that
easy to get all the guys to say yes to
come on the show
yeah definitely um you know it was we
talk
every week all five all of you
oh yeah yeah definitely yeah um
so you know and this quarantine has kind
of brought us even closer because you
know you're
you spend more time you know in your
group text and all that
uh but yeah i mean when i wanted to do
something special for the anniversary
uh i called you guys like hey let me
just do
one-on-one hard-hitting interviews with
each one of you individually because
i haven't been able to do that as long
as i've been hosting radio and all that
i've never interviewed all all four guys
before
um and so it was it's very special
it went very long i felt bad i mean
there was i think justin's interview
went for an hour and a half
um that's not long at some of these
interviews some people have three hours
rogan three hours i'm like i i want this
to be an hour i'm looking at the clock
now i go i could talk to lance forever
but like
an hour hour and 15 that's like that's
the i don't want to talk that long i
can't
yeah this day and age people like you
know small bikes i mean even an
hour is too long for people but yeah i
like it i like to keep my show under an
hour
um but it's so difficult when you have a
great yes
yeah and like danny trejo was on my show
this weekend and
he's just he has such incredible stories
he has such a colorful life
like it just went on forever because i
couldn't stop i couldn't not talk about
some of the things i wanted to talk
about
so i have to interview him you know i
met him a couple of times he's like hey
man take my number
and then i was like okay but i never
called him i think i still have danny
he won't even remember that guy but let
me end this you know he has tacos and
donuts
oh yeah i've eaten them you know that
you go way back you remember i remember
hearing you know you were really upset
you were crushed you were devastated
when justin like left and blah blah blah
and all that stuff and then you rekindle
and you were fine and everything's great
right in a nutshell oh yeah me and the
guys were never
on bad terms at all it's just you know
life goes on and you you know you have
more interest and you have to focus on
your careers and it's great
uh the thing i was most disappointed in
was not just justin leaving the band
um it's that our whole team our record
label our management everything like
that
they all knew they all knew it was it
was over
for three years and you didn't before
before they told me
and so for three years i'm sitting there
getting ready for a new album
as everyone else knows we're moving on
and so i didn't get i turned down you
know i had a sitcom i was doing had to
turn it down
uh i mean there's all kinds of stuff
that i really wanted to
do and focus on but i knew i couldn't
because you know
i'm my first commitment in sync like
this is my life
you could have been writing you could
have been doing well i mean you were
sure you're writing but you could have
been like doing other
you know going out yeah it would have
been nice to kind of you know
set up a little better before you know
going out solo were you guys
i mean you had to get annoyed i get
annoyed with my brother all the time
when you're on the road
together who's the one guy that you were
just like oh my god
[ __ ] off i mean there had to be those
moments where you're like
you can't love you dove everybody you
had to get little things like oh yeah
well that's the thing with you know with
us and that's why we're so close we're
brothers
i mean we love each other we hate each
other every single emotion comes out
when you're in a brother relationship
um so yeah many times that the good
thing about us
is if we fight we make up very quickly
like we
we kind of forget things because i think
we're just guys but like just
we we don't hold on to things too much
but the one that would always
uh make my eyes roll would uh
would be chris kirkpatrick in interviews
uh because chris you know he's very
animated and he's funny and he's always
cracking a joke
but when someone is always cracking the
joke in every single inner
review like they do 20 a day and there's
five guys
your days get long and long and long so
there'd be many times i'm like just shut
up like just answer the questions so we
can move on because we're so tired right
now so
he would always yeah make all our
interviews at least double the time
what was the biggest blowout you could
remember we're all five or you were just
like [ __ ] off i don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm with him you're with it that you're
just going
i don't know we never had that situation
i don't think we had the time
to have that one happen no i mean we
never
i remember this one time the the biggest
fight i ever saw
um you couldn't even call it a real
fight we were in miami doing challenge
for the children our charity
uh fighting that we do
and uh we were getting ready we were so
tired because we had been out the night
before
and it's just like a whole three day
event and um we have to do press the
next morning so we're all up in
the hotel room and we're all meeting
there and then we're gonna go down and
do all the press
um and then joy was late like he was
about 15 minutes late
you know we're all tired all right and
they had sent
food you know from room service and so
we had all this room service food like
burgers and all that type of stuff
we're eating and joey had ordered a
burger um well justin as a joke
took the burger and took a huge bite of
it and put it back right
holy moly there was something up joey's
butt that day because when he came in
and he saw someone bit his hamburger
he was like not doing it and he like
protested i i'm not leaving here until i
get a new burger it was like
it was so funny i've never seen joey get
so upset about something like that but
you can tell he was probably tired or
something he was just over it at that
moment he's like nope
it is you know i'm going to stand on
this crown and i am not leaving here
until the burger gets here
so we always we make fun of them all the
time for that outburst
all of this does anybody anybody then go
come on dude seriously dude it's a
[ __ ] burger come on
did it start getting heated we're like
you're really gonna make no never
this is disrespect somebody ate my
burger i
[ __ ] it that's how it happened it just
blew up
at a charity event
inside of you is brought to you by
better help online counseling if you
don't have better help if you haven't
tried it and you're like
most of us in the world that have a
little depression or a little anxiety
you're suffering from many different
things and you're just
uh you know hopefully we're normalizing
it here on the show but if
you still are really private and a lot
of people are better help is actually
perfect for you
better help offers licensed professional
counselors who are trained to listen
and help you could talk with your
counselor in a private
online environment at your own
convenience from wherever you're
comfortable
better help counselors have expertise in
a broad range of areas not only
depression anxiety but
the list goes on loss anger family
conflicts
lgbt issues um
uh betterhelp can give you access to
help that may not be available in your
area
and it's so easy guys i mean i can do
this all you do is
you fill out a questionnaire to help
assess your specific needs you get
matched with your counselor in under 48
hours
so if you're stressed you don't have to
go i have to look for a counselor now i
it might take weeks i have to talk to a
friend now people have to whatever it is
this these guys work fast and they're
going to help you
easily schedule secure video or phone
sessions with your therapist plus
exchange unlimited messages which is
good for
someone like me everything you share is
of course confidential
so you don't feel weird about calling
them if for any reason you're unhappy
with your counselor and you know what
sometimes it takes a couple of
counselors
you can request a new one at any time no
additional charge
so remember that you know i always tell
my friends you don't
have to if you don't like your counselor
it doesn't mean therapy is not right for
me
you try another counselor sometimes it's
got to be the right fit where you feel
comfortable and that's
that's the most important thing join the
million plus people taking charge of
their mental health
with the help of an experienced better
health counselor in fact so many people
have been using better health they are
currently recruiting additional
counselors in all 50 states
better help is an affordable option and
our listeners get 10
off your first month with the discount
code inside
get started today at betterhelp.com
inside that's betterhelp
inside talk to a therapist online and
get
help have you ever dealt with uh anxiety
depression you get all that stuff i mean
is on the road doing these things do you
find yourself also what's happening in
my body
i mean i think we all get anxieties in
certain ways um i wouldn't call myself
an anxious person
uh my husband is so i i know
dating him has really
uh really educated me on people with
anxiety because i always thought that i
had anxiety oh no
no no when someone really has it it's
crippling and my husband's very
uh very anxious um and you know it's it
took me a while to kind of get used to
and
and realize how to deal with that um but
yeah the only i mean
i don't know if i get too anxious uh on
anything i mean i do get
like excited nervous before i go out on
a stage
but i i love that anxious feeling like
it gives me i don't know i think i
feel like i do you know a better
performance if i'm a little nervous
you don't get that tired kind of oh my
god i'm so nervous i'm exhausted now
this adrenaline's making me tired
no no not at all no i my my energy
levels are definitely
off the charts still still yeah
yeah wow yeah well do what about like
depression do you ever like
are you one of those guys like i all of
a sudden my mind can wander
you know it could get i could sit there
and go you're a [ __ ] disgrace
yeah why the [ __ ] did you do that why
you're such a loser do you ever go down
that
oh yeah i mean i've been dealing with
depression for the last 15 years
um and again i think everyone has a
level of depression that they always are
having to deal with
um but i think my depression was
definitely an onset of a couple of
things you know
having to come out so publicly you know
it was very
scary um but then also um
i wait okay so what was i just saying
for that
well you're talking about you know you
know you have that good anxious feeling
when you were on stage and then you were
saying
you know the depression you've had for
15 years because yeah you know
everything
that's what i was thinking so i mean
depression for entertainers i think is a
whole different level
um i think if you if you're in the
business and you have a certain level of
success
i think anyone's going to get depressed
after
that kind of goes down right because
you're you're like in this weird
zeitgeist of this like instinct world
where every hour is booked and
everything you do is successful
and like it's just your life is
wonderful right and then all that stops
and then you don't know what to do
you're like wait and so you go in this
depression of
okay no one likes me what am i supposed
to do how am i like
what do people want me to do and and
then trying to figure that out
yeah i mean you get more and more
depressed because you feel like
just no one cares about you like what's
my purpose like what am i supposed to do
as part of this and then
obviously you've changed that look at
you i mean if you think about that then
i think that's the one thing where
you know you have to look now and say
you know that was that was like winning
the lottery it's like getting a huge tv
show or whatever you win the lottery
chances are you're not going to win the
lottery again you're not going to win a
winnebago again
you know these girls are not going to
win so when you have that kind of
success
and then i guess you start to grow up
and you start to find
what really makes me tick and then
that's what you did that was sort of
like
your journey it's like oh my god what do
i do next and then now you see all these
things lined up and these things that
you're doing and you know you get
married you want to have kids and
it's just like i wish that i maybe some
of the unnecessary depression or anxiety
that i have would just be if i could
have a glimpse of the future see it's
okay
it worked out why do you but last
question before i just do
this is a speed round with uh a patreon
p my patrons have [ __ ] talking questions
for lance and that will be quick
but this is always something i thought
of when
uh you know i'm not gay as of right now
but you know if i were and
certainly sexuality is questioned
because in high school people will say
you're a [ __ ]
or oh you're a homo especially in
indiana right people say these things
and there's like oh yeah rosenbaum rosie
palm he jerks off he's gay
so i didn't know anything so i i there
wasn't an internet no one was teaching
me so i go
oh wow i do play with myself i guess
maybe i am gay
is that what they're saying so what i'm
trying to say to you is
did you ever feel like you had to be
part of the ignorance by saying
words that you would not with it almost
were really directed at you
hurtful things that you'd say yeah you'd
say the by the way sorry for saying the
f word but i was kind of saying like
what people said to me
but do you do you did you know it's true
i mean especially
you know in junior high and high school
you know you go along with those gay
jokes because
you didn't want anyone to find out who
you are so i would definitely repeat
those gay jokes just to make it seem
like you know i'm definitely not gay so
yeah you'd have to
i guess self-preserve as much as you
thought you should be doing
yeah and i also think you know some guys
like you you dated girls
you had sex with women right how do you
do that like i i don't
like you know what i mean like how how
can you have sex with something you're
not attracted to i know well i mean
the things that you'll make yourself do
just to be accepted i mean that's that's
what i mean
so many gay people have to do uh because
one you feel like your life would be in
danger
if you didn't do this like i mean you
literally thought that someone's going
to murder you if they found out you were
gay
so you know the things that you you know
put yourself through yes i had
girlfriends
um you know yes i would have sex with
girls but
i always tell people because i'm like
wow could you do that now i don't think
i don't think i could ever be with a
woman like i just i'm not attracted to
women and i don't think i could
physically be with a woman but when
you're 18
you know you can do anything so it was a
lot easier
when you're a teenager to pretend you're
straight uh but now at 41 i'd be like
she's gonna know that i'm not into this
but you think of something else while
you're having sex you're obviously
thinking of a guy
right um no actually wow
really it was always the thing that like
excited me was seeing her get excited
like being turned on and everything so
like that that you know excited me
wasn't anything
uh like i would never think of penises
and all that type of stuff but uh
but yeah i was it was just i liked the
idea that i was pleasuring someone i
still think you're that person that
you're you're you're not selfish you're
thinking of their pleasure
sure yeah i'll take care of yourself
sometimes all right
this is called [ __ ] talking questions
then we'll be done this is great [ __ ]
talking these are my patrons who are
just amazing
uh folks and they have some questions
i'm just gonna throw uh
rapid fire all right yes janelle
bettencourt what's your
go-to karaoke song um friends in low
places garth brooks
really oh yeah it is the biggest crowd
pleaser at karaoke
one i hate karaoke um it's public
karaoke like if you go to cat's meow new
orleans you'll never see me on that
stage like
um private karaoke love it when you get
your own room it's awesome
love that but i will never sing in front
of strangers at karaoke well you're a
bass right
yes so yeah that's another thing it's
hard to find bassy songs in karaoke
and that opens with one right so how
does that go blame it all on your roots
i showed up in there
yeah you go and blow places where the
whiskey drowns and the beer
chases my i just love country music too
oh me too i do like country
i do like some old country ronnie
millsap some eddie rabbit
lisa williams little lisa what was your
favorite thing and least favorite thing
about touring when you were with nsync
um my favorite thing was
having my friends and family out on the
road at times and
you know i have all these really fun
road trip adventures with your high
school friends
um i was i loved being able to share my
experience with my best friends
because they just had you know we were
19 years old so
like you know everyone was having so
much fun on the road and you could be
stupid and
you know it was such an innocent time
back then um
and then the least favorite thing was
just being tired all the time i mean you
just
you're always so tired being on the road
who [ __ ] up the most in terms of the
notes you're like dude you didn't hit
that note you were at [ __ ] you're out of
sync
you did that i mean we all definitely
hold our ground
uh but i mean of course everyone's gonna
have those crazy off notes
um we've all had them especially when
you know
you'll be on a tv show and they're like
all sperm they're like
single acapella and you're like well
crap cause obviously all the mics are
gonna be different
you know right you know loudness and
stuff so it's not gonna sound that great
so those were always like we hated we
hated being surprised by uh
by singing acapellas because we knew it
wasn't gonna sound as great if we were
all on
separate mics raj which member of the
band was hooking up the most while you
guys were on tour if you're
uncomfortable naming names
which you won't be just describe their
hairstyle in 1999
i'll figure it out well it definitely
wasn't me
that is for show um i don't know i mean
during most of the instinct run the guys
were
all pretty much in like serious
relationships so no one really
we weren't that kind of rock star
lifestyle where you were you know taking
a fan home every night i could just we
never
i never saw drugs on the road i never
you know it was just we were
we were a very innocent band sadly
because i think we would have had a lot
more fun but we had a lot of
parental types around us from the record
label management you know they really
kept us
reined in um a lot so yeah there was and
there was just really no time
like there was no time to date so how
are you supposed to just kind of like
find a girl that you
saw at a concert and then go home
because you're on the road the next like
before the music even stops on tour
you're on the bus
going to the next city like you're not
staying there raj the short answer is jc
and uh justin i wish you would seriously
jason was too much for prude though
uh maisha love says you've got your own
podcast a deli pop a popcast with lance
bassel you have mr rosenbaum as a guest
i had to read it
you better believe it hell yeah i was on
your other your podcast
oh yeah years ago the dirty pop a long
time ago oh yeah
all right this one is the last question
and this i'm glad it's the last question
because i this is why i sort of text you
about this
todd the 206 geek is is it true you
tried to purchase the brady bunch house
but hd
tv sniped it out from under you that is
true
yes um i had this you know one of my tv
shows i wanted to do was this show where
you take iconic
homes from film and television and you
redo them you know and like put them
back on the market whatever
um so always knew if the brady bunch
ever came for sale
i was going to do this show so uh
you know it you know went up for sale
i'm like i got this i'm doing it so
you know we started this amazing bidding
war with miley cyrus and all these other
people like it was a kind of a fun
event right um and
i called hgtv and i was like hey you
know if i get this house i want to do a
show
on hgtv where we you know redo these
houses
well that was a mistake because guess
what
after two weeks of bidding and
the real estate agent calls he's like
congratulations you got the house like
you have the winning bid
and we're like this is amazing we
celebrate i tweeted i'm like i'm gonna
do the brady house blah blah
the next day they call they're like oh
sorry
hgtv has called and said that they're
just gonna give us whatever money we
want like they'll outbid anyone
so it's like well why did we have a
bidding war for two weeks and spending a
lot of money on lawyers doing bidding
for two weeks when you're just going to
give it to a network
at the end they were using us to put up
the price leverage because they knew
that you should have
i hope you sued those bastards that's
terrible what can you do
i mean it's not technically illegal so
so you didn't watch when they redid the
house did you even watch that or you're
like [ __ ] them
i did actually um because hdtv wanted me
to play nice because when the fans found
out that they stole it
they got a lot of heat and people were
like boycotting the show already like
room never watch the show
so they call me they're like we would
love you to be involved you know like
because
you're like you can at least produce the
show with us like fine i'll help produce
it
that never happened they were just
basically lying to me to get me out of
the way and not talk
[ __ ] about them um and then they did
let me do um i got to tour the house
with michael
um and it was incredible oh my gosh
it was it was incredible so we got to
tour the whole house and we did the
behind the scenes
type of stuff for their uh their website
and all that
but it was they did a really spectacular
job can you still can you actually i
would die
i i honestly i would do anything i would
donate whatever to charity
if you could somehow get me a private
tour of that house oh that can happen
yeah i'm look i'm still trying to buy
the house because http still doesn't
know what they want to do with the house
and i'm like why would i work on a house
like sell it to me like
let's like why why would you want to
hold on to this house like give it to
someone that
really wants this house uh well you know
what why don't we come up with a sitcom
and it could just have all the brady
bunch
furniture and the house and the inside
and we just do our own show i'm like why
why are all this furniture 60 years old
i don't know we never we never talk
about it i love it
oh my god well hey man this is i
honestly this is the
the easiest quickest back and forth i
mean
i'll ask my listeners but uh this has
been great i mean we got so much
we talked about so much and it was in an
hour look at there we made the hour
i love i love seeing you i think you
look fantastic i'm so excited for you
and michael i think it's beautiful i
feel it's the end of the year it's gonna
be a little christmas present for you
it's gonna happen and uh yeah
i hope so now i love seeing you i can't
wait to be able to like
see you in person give you a big hug all
right thanks for allowing me to be
inside of you again
of course wait this is the first time
it's the first time i was inside of you
yeah yeah first time but not the last
not the last all right
i like lance don't you it's a good guy
yeah he is he's just
you know i think it's it's funny when
you look back and you see pictures of
him
and he's he's a kid he's a young kid he
gets a superstar i don't know i would
have jumped off a roof i couldn't
i could barely handle no success or
a teenager medium success man i couldn't
imagine being so young and just like
people just launching themselves at you
that kind of success i don't think it's
a rarity and i don't know be careful
what you wish
for yeah but uh he seems to have a good
head on his shoulder he found out who he
is
you know i mean he i think he always
knew it's like you know he talks about
it yeah
but when you could find your soulmate
and you can go hey you know when he
talks about dating like
i'm dating the wrong guys and i'm like
well you know you date the wrong girls
and you're like
but this is my type this is my type and
then one day you go let's go against the
type
and you find it yeah you find the one i
think that's a beautiful story and
i always wish him the best and uh i'm
bummed that he can't get me he texts me
back i'm sorry they're not doing any
tours for the brady bunch house i tried
for you
so [ __ ] you lance
you're a liar no uh man
i'm so bummed i actually might call hgtv
and just say dude i'll give
a thousand bucks to charity maybe i
could bring a
a patron or a listener or whatever maybe
like you know if i can
get a hold of somebody and you know have
a little little thing on my podcast like
hey the winner
you know if you're you know you'll come
with me to the brady bunch house and
people are like big
deal is preston too young too
i don't think he'd know the brady bunch
she'd be bored my good buddy preston
shout out to preston christensen
uh cheerleader uh music extraordinaire
uh cancer survivor he is he is still uh
working at it and it's in remission
and i love him i love you uh you know
preston and i love the family and
and i can't wait to see you this whole
pandemic has screwed things over and
shout out to food on foot
and um helping the homeless they need
your help more than ever
ronald mcdonald house and the animal
rescue mission
of course shira hopefully people will
come
and help okay we're going to read the uh
the patrons names now by the way if
you're hearing these names you're like
what is this
well these are the top tier patrons if
you go to patreon.com they support the
show in
many great ways and uh they're the top
tier and part of that top tier is you
get your name
called off in the uh in the podcast
so it's a cool thing and i like saying
the names i hope they like hearing their
names
so here they are nancy d mary b leah s
trish f cereville lisa you kiko
mm-hmm where have you been yukiko i miss
you uh hopefully i'll see you at the
stage at the next stage
brian h lauren g jill e
nico p angelina g robin
asked jerry wood emily k bob b robert b
jason w stephen j kristen k not to be
confused with kristen
crook that's correct amelia oh oh oh
allison l l tom and jess j
lucas m raj raj
c raj she
see how i did that emily s cjp samantha
m
hamza jennifer and jackie p stacy b
carly t jennifer s janelle b carrie b
tab with the 272 not to be confused with
that with the 273 kimberly e crystal h
mike e
marissa ann ramirez beth b chris f
santiago
m sarah f chad w liam p
rachen that's rachel we know we know
roshan
w rey a maya p maya p my
ho megan d jennifer c maddie s
tiffany i kendrick f ashley e
margie m thomas t matt w belinda and
benjamin are lisa j kevin v
robert s mike w james r chris h snow r
noah k sean v ashborne
k osborne osbjorn ospion ospion we love
you
uh and dave h and if you're listening to
these names
um again they're they have joined
patreon they're in the top tier and then
part of being on the top tier
you get your name mentioned on the
podcast so there you go those are the
the patrons i love you
thank you for all the support i remember
go to the inside of you online store if
you want cool merch like ryan has the
towel
there's wine glasses now i don't know
how many are left i just saw you hit
your mic it's fine
that's fine it's really about it that's
fine anyway this has been grand
i uh i love you all thank you for
listening we got great episodes coming
up we got that uh
the vow coming up in a few weeks uh
someone who you know lived it if you
don't know anything about it you're
gonna want to hear it it's an amazing
story and a lot of great guests kevin
smith coming up dak
shepard we got uh bruce campbell from
the evil dead movies
uh so many great guests um another guest
from the show
psych it's just it's it's endless please
keep listening please subscribe and
i love doing this and hopefully you like
listening ryan thank you
thank you bryce thank you all right
thank you for allowing me to be inside
of each and every one of you
until next time thank you goodbye